In August 2020, while Europe was
on the cusp of a devastating
second wave of Covid-19,
and the U.S. was struggling to find beds
for its sickest patients with the virus,
this was happening in Russia.
But the rest of the world wasn't so sure.
Russia has become the first country to
give regulatory approval
to a Covid-19 vaccine.
But there are myriad questions
and concerns already. A vaccine so quickly
and from a country notorious
for propaganda and deception.
The issue is not about the
science of the vaccine.
It's about the approach that was used
by the Russian government,
in terms of approving
and starting to use the
vaccine before the phase three
clinical trial data was in.
Starting to use the vaccine,
starting to try to export the vaccine
and launching this entire
propaganda campaign
actually worked against the product.
After first facing scrutiny
on whether Russia's
vaccines actually work,
now the question has become
whether they can meet worldwide demand.
Critics and observers
are now left wondering is
the Kremlin playing vaccine
politics as part of a campaign
to undercut Western powers
and their technology?
Or is this a case of solid
science being tainted
by allegations of Russian
hacking, poisonings
and interference in democratic elections.
Russia's scrambling
to bring Covid-19 under control.
Russia is battling a surge in Covid cases.
The virus came late to Russia,
but it is definitely here now.
Russia reported its first Covid-19 cases
in January in Siberia
and Russia's far East.
By July, officials reported
almost 840,000 cases.
And more than 30,000 excessive deaths.
Global health experts however,
have questioned the
accuracy of Russia's data,
deeming the number of
Covid related fatalities
too low given infection rates.
Russia acted very swiftly
to impose restrictions.
It was one of the first
countries to enact a total ban
on the entry of Chinese citizens.
And by late March, it had
imposed a shutdown of its borders
and a series of lockdowns
across the country.
Meanwhile, in Moscow,
the Gamaleya Research Institute
of Epidemiology and Microbiology named
after pioneering Russian
vaccine researcher
Nikolay Gamaleya got to work.
They called the project Sputnik V.
Sputnik V is a reference
to a very important date
in Soviet history, which was the launch
of the world's first
satellite, Sputnik, in 1957
and that marked the
start of the Space Race
between the Soviet Union
and the United States.
In naming it after that, it's clear
that Russia was positioning
itself as a player in a
geopolitical struggle.
The first artificial Earth satellite,
a world-stirring event.
By May, the Gamaleya Institute had already
started testing their vaccine
on the center's director
as well as key scientific staff.
A move which seemed to place Russia ahead
of other countries in the vaccine race.
The institute supplied vaccines
for use against the Ebola outbreak
in Guinea in 2017 to 2018.
The Covid-19 vaccine
that they developed
was based on technology
they had earlier applied in
an experimental inoculation
against the deadly Middle
East Respiratory Syndrome
or MERS.
And that's what allowed Russia to go ahead
relatively quickly in
developing a Covid-19 vaccine.
But on August 11th,
when President Putin announced
that Sputnik had been registered
as the world's first Covid-19 vaccine,
it hadn't started vital
phase three trials,
prompting worry among
the scientific community
and mockery from the Trump administration.
I was extraordinarily surprised
to see that announcement in August.
I'm not surprised that
they were working on it,
not surprised they started
the clinical trials,
but very surprised and
a little bit disturbed
to see them starting to use
it before they had the data.
For Putin it was clearly very important
to be first in the world
to release and approve a vaccine.
And so the entire state
propaganda apparatus
worked overtime
to present this as a huge
victory for Russian science,
for the Russian pharma
industry and basically as proof
of Russia's superiority
in areas where the country
has long been written off.
Isn't it premature for Russia to
have approved this vaccine
before phase three trials
are substantially underway?
No, not at all.
First we were criticized
but then we saw that
Britain announced that
they may follow suit.
U.S. FDA said that they may want
to register before phase three.
The suspicion that this is
a propaganda tool rather
than actually a way to fight
Covid-19 was obviously there
and it was expectable that reaction.
The Putin government has
done a lot of ugly things
to earn the suspicion and
distrust of especially
Western nations.
So obviously there was a
certain handicap to overcome
and that could not be done
with premature fanfare.
It could only be counteracted
with scientific proof
and scientific proof was
eventually delivered.
On February 2nd,
in the esteemed medical
journal The Lancet,
vaccine experts, professors,
Polly Roy and Ian Jones
reported that Sputnik V appeared safe
with an efficacy rate of 91.6%.
This was really a chance
for Russia to dispel a lot
of the skepticism surrounding
the vaccine and you know
whether it was actually
good at combating Covid-19.
I think it's fair to say that
demand increased as a result
of that breakthrough.
In Europe, there has definitely
been a change of sentiment.
There are shortages of
the vaccine in Europe.
So, you know, now the EU
is looking at a request to
approve the use of Sputnik V.
In addition to that several
European countries, France
Germany, Spain and Italy
may also manufacture it.
So it's definitely fair to say
that there was a change of heart.
Sputnik is very similar to
both the AstraZeneca vaccine
and the Johnson and Johnson
vaccine in that it's
an adenovirus vectored vaccine.
And what that means is that
they're using a common cold
virus to deliver a little bit
of the Covid virus
to your own cells and
sort of tricks your cells
into making just a little
bit of the Covid virus.
And with that little bit,
which is the spike protein
your body's able to
mount an immune response
so you develop T-cells,
you develop antibodies
that all respond to Covid-19
if you should get infected in the future.
Sputnik V is also double
vectored, which means
that it uses a slightly different version
of the vaccine in the second dose.
So protection against
Covid-19 could last longer.
I don't necessarily think that in terms
of the vaccine itself and
how it works in the body
it exhibits any advantages
over the mRNA system.
Now vaccines like
Sputnik, like AstraZeneca
and like the Johnson and Johnson vaccine
that are all adenovirus vector vaccines
are much more stable
in warmer temperatures.
And so that makes this
cold-chain much easier.
That means the storage and the
distribution is much easier.
And so all of that is a
real positive strength.
The AstraZeneca and
Johnson and Johnson shots
have in rare cases, been
connected to blood clots.
Russian officials claim that
Sputnik though developed
in the same way hasn't
caused similar side effects.
All of this combined
with a relatively low
production cost of $10 a dose,
makes Sputnik V a viable option
for developing countries
that are struggling
to either obtain or
distribute inoculations.
But there are questions
about how much politics
will impact the vaccine's distribution.
We do not do politics.
And obviously vaccine is
our effort to save people
and it should not be politicized.
Russia clearly has been using the vaccine,
Sputnik V, as a way to
bolster its global ambitions.
In Latin America for example,
Argentina has already had deliveries
of two and a half million doses.
It's ordered a total of 20 million.
Mexico is another big buyer they've asked
for 24 million doses.
Russia hasn't asked any
countries to pay a premium.
However, it's not offering any discounts
for poorer countries.
So in Latin America or Africa
the price is the same as anywhere else
and that's approximately $10 a shot.
and we know that some
Western manufacturers
are providing discounts
for developing countries.
However, Russia's pharma industry,
wasn't prepared for the level
of demand for Sputnik V.
The RDIF, Russia's
sovereign wealth fund, who
were financing the vaccine
had to strike production deals
around the world to
support the global supply
for Sputnik V abroad.
There are definitely
still problems in ramping
up production.
Russia's total production of Sputnik V
since the pandemic started
is less than the number
of vaccine shots
administered every two weeks
to the U.S. population.
It is now promising
to produce much larger quantities.
Particularly in India it
has a very ambitious target
of 700 million two dose sets,
which it is hoping to get manufactured
outside Russia this year.
Closer to home,
there's been a lack of
enthusiasm for the vaccine.
With a recent poll revealing that 62%
of respondents wouldn't take Sputnik V.
Despite ordering mass
inoculations in January,
Putin himself didn't get
vaccinated until seven months
after the August announcement.
The Kremlin said he was
focusing on other inoculations.
It was not made public
which of the Russian vaccines he received.
In a way that the
traditional Russian mistrust
of authority has made it easier
for the government
because the demand for
the vaccine is not as high
as it would have been elsewhere.
In Russia, you can get it if you want it,
but many just don't want to
and perhaps even Putin's own slowness
in getting vaccinated is
indicative of, you know,
how cautious Russians are
about this whole thing.
Russia has been hit especially hard
by the pandemic with at least
250,000 epidemic-linked deaths
Russian officials said.
But the country could now
hold a powerful weapon in
the fight against the virus.
I think the Sputnik vaccine
will be a very powerful tool.
I think we still have a few questions
that need to be answered.
I still think we want
to see the final data
at the end of May when the
phase three trial is due to end
and all of the safety data.
So yes, a few small bits of
data that I would like to see
but I think the Sputnik
vaccine will absolutely
be a very powerful tool in
the global vaccine campaign
as well as many other
vaccines that are both being
developed right now, or being
used in other countries.
We just need to combine
that sort of manufacturing
and distribution with that
solid clinical evaluation.
And I think that we are doing that.
It's made a huge difference
to Russia's image.
Definitely a very good
tool of soft diplomacy,
which has shown that Russia
has the capacity to play
an important role in
combating this pandemic.